et pour parler nous sommes en direct
avec andré bercoff journaliste et
écrivain mais super coq bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté de transit à sion sur rt
france alors donald trump n'est pas le
premier président américain dont la
santé fait l'actualité mais dans une
certaine limite
la santé des présidents c'est un jeu
d'équilibriste entre transparence et
secret bien gardé
bah écoutez il y a eu quelque chose de
très spécial
il y a eu un livre au sommet qui est
paru dans les années soixante dix et on
peut entourer de pierre accoce ça
s'appelle ces malades qui nous
gouvernent
ces malades qui nous gouvernent il
disait exactement salle ce que disait
votre votre journaliste sur la santé est
effectivement en france c'est secret
d'état et a le secret en amérique c'est
le contraire mais je dois dire que le 4
1 p très intéressant parce que comme
d'habitude et c'est vraiment sa
stratégie depuis toujours en tout cas
depuis qui s'est présenté en politique
il ya quatre ans un peu plus de quatre
ans cinq ans maintenant il fait de sa
faiblesse une force c'est très
intéressant l'histoire de kobe tu parce
que bon il a été déclaré malade
il est à l'hôpital évidemment les
rumeurs les plus folles sorte l'auberge
espagnole des fantasmes explose
et puis qu'est ce qu'il fait y voilà
j'ai été guérie ses médecins le disent
et surtout je ne peux pas transmettre
dont il revient à son occupation la plus
importante c'est le meeting trump sans
contact c'est plus train et si le la
maladie aurait été déclaré et il aurait
aggravé
là il était très mal barré aujourd'hui
les choses sont très ouvertes parce que
justement il va pouvoir pendant que joe
biden est plutôt quand même qu'elle
ferait lui va pouvoir à mort reprend
pendant les trois semaines ou un peu
moins d'un mois qui restent on va
reprendre ses meetings etc
qu'est ce que ça va donner on ne va pas
jouer les voyantes ici mais c'est clair
que pour lui c'est doux bénéfices
pourquoi parce qu'il est renvoyé je suis
comme vous j'ai affronté
dragons le dragon coheed jeu les vaincus
on peut le vaincre et n'ai pas peur
comme disait le pape alors est-ce que ça
va jouer et à quel point ça va jouer on
ne sait pas les sondages vous savez très
bien que les sondages en 2016 donné la
veille du scrutin hillary clinton
gagnante à 80% donc tout est ouvert et
tout est possible mais on voit bien
comment donald trump utilisent cette
stratégie vraiment pour dire regardez
moi je suis là je suis vainqueur je me
bats je me bats je me bats et en
amérique on aime assez ça on voit bien
pour que pour le cadre des états unis en
tout cas que c'est un enjeu politique la
santé du président américain en tout cas
dans le cas de figure de donald trump on
avions également que tous les coups sont
permis
si je puis dire du côté des américain
joe biden a d'ailleurs régulièrement
attaqué donald trump sur son état de
santé sur son âge et ton à l'abri de ce
type de méthode en france selon vous
écouter on n'est à l'abri de rien en
france disons qu'en france c'est aussi
violent mais plus policé l'effleuré son
mouchetés on met des caches
mais aujourd'hui justement avec les
réseaux sociaux et moi je ne trouve pas
que c'est forcément quelque chose de
mauvais les choses sortent
évidemment on n'est pas à l'abri surtout
la prochaine présidentielle nous c'est
en 2022 et ça risque d'être extrêmement
violent aussi à tout point de vue
donc tout est possible simplement en
france on ne s'affrontent pas clairement
vous l'avez dit on a parlé des secrets
etc
et c'est vrai que ça joue sauf qu'encore
une fois les réseaux sociaux ont tout
changé il savait très très difficile y
compris en france wire de garder des
secrets
quitte à ce que ce soit des opérations
intox mais ces opérations un bloc seront
démentis moi je crois vraiment qu'il
faut mieux je pense à laissac les
américains c'est moi j'aime bien cette
politique américaine de la transparence
je pense que la transparence quand on
est à ce niveau-là de chefs d'état quand
on est on est pilote d'un pays quand on
est vraiment à la barre il vaut mieux
que les gens savent
sache que vous l'êtes pas handicapées ou
malades
vous parliez du pouvoir des réseaux
sociaux
est ce que finalement aujourd'hui il n'y
a plus de limite entre la vie publique
et la vie privée
je crois que la limite devient de plus
en plus faible sinon inexistante
effectivement ça a tout changé
mais pour le meilleur et pour le pire
c'est qu'on le parle que du pire en
général en disant ah c'est terrible ce
terrible non c'est pas terrible
c'est très bien beaucoup de choses
seraient ignorés du public en france et
ailleurs
si les réseaux sociaux ne jouaient pas
leur rôle après à chacun de prier le bon
grain de l'ivraie et deux aînés son
esprit critique parce que vous avez de
quoi choisir il ya le grain à moudre
donc il faut choisir mais
personnellement je crois qu'à partir du
moment où on est à ce degré en politique
à ce stade je parle des stades
extrêmement pourtant au sommet on ne
peut pas cacher des choses
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec mis
tous regardé ce qui se passait avec qui
l'accusation de de venir de harcèlement
sexuel ou autre alors autant c'est
extrêmement désagréable autant
effectivement exciper utiliser son
pouvoir pour faire du harcèlement aussi
ce n'est pas très joli joli
donc voilà c'est un risque à prendre des
risques à courir et je pense que l'homme
politique conséquent un homme d'état
surtout peut les affronter
dernière question très rapidement qui
peut aujourd'hui finalement en france
précisément décidé de la santé enfin de
l'état de santé du président s'il est
possible de continuer à assumer ses
fonctions est ce que ses médecins
personnels ont le droit
finalement deux
de dénier le secret médical c'est tout
le problème si vous voulez aujourd'hui
effectivement le médecin personnel ou
autres et est assigné à son devoir de
réserve et au secret médical est ce
qu'on peut changer la loi de ce point de
vue là je ne sais pas mais encore une
fois je crois qu'il ya loin d'un côté et
puis le certaine morale de l'autre je
pense que dans certains cas et je le
répète si un homme politique qui a un
pouvoir extrêmement important sur la vie
des citoyens en tout cas sur le devenir
des citoyens n'a pas le peut pas et ça
fait partie pour moi de la morale et du
civisme ne peut pas cacher sur l'état de
santé
si celui-ci l'handicapé je trouve que
effectivement on pourrait se poser des
problèmes ce qui s'est passé avec
pompidou et avec mitterrand comme on l'a
dit moi je crois que la transparence de
ce point de vue autant la transparence
sur la vie privée vous gêne énormément
les les secrets d'alcôve tout ça c'est
mes soit la santé serait en revanche
voilà merci beaucoup en tout quinze
jours et merci à andré bercoff d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
écrivain